well after so many tough months the
future in las vegas looking a lot
brighter but recovery takes a while and
so many are still struggling
now two local kids have started an
amazing movement to bring
local families bicycles sasha loftus
joining us live tonight with more
on their message brian these two girls
are changing the world
one bike at a time after seeing so many
kids across las vegas struggling
they decided to step up and help
hundreds of local families
turning two wheels into an amazing gift
just knowing you made an impact on
someone's life is just wow
as families across las vegas continue to
face tough times
ayanna castro and bella hawkins are
stepping in
to make a difference we had seen a
drastic drop
in kids and teens mental health due to
being isolated from
quarantines and the pandemic and we
wanted to do something to help them out
at just 12 and 15 years old the girls
have created a
and b's bike spring fling a movement to
collect hundreds of new
and gently used bikes for local kids to
use for transportation
and to improve physical and mental
health it's phenomenal and i think it
sets a
you know it sets the bar high and it
lets others see
you know if they can do it i can do it
too and give back to the community as
you can see
they're off to a good start as they add
to their lot here at storage one
but they need more by the end of april
so they're calling on the community for
help
and donations most people haven't lived
through a pandemic before
so this is all something new to us all
something that we're like
discovering together it's been a long
dark road
but thanks to people like ayanna and
bella the future
looks a whole lot brighter we're all
going to get through this
i mean stay positive now ayanna and
bella are accepting donations through
the end of april to make those
deliveries
in the beginning of may now they are
looking of course for bicycles of all
sizes along with trike bikes for
children with disabilities and even
helmets or just monetary donations
if you'd like to help out we have more
information on our website 8newsnow.com
reporting live in the newsroom tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now